we've been looking ratios how do we
ratios ratios are about when you compare
one quantity to another you can we can
tell I've had my five of the movies
recently so just just bear with me okay
now Thor and Hulk they have kind of this
song which they say it's a bit of a
friendly rivalry or not that's my worry
okay so in the climactic battle okay
there and they're trying to compete for
how many probably bad guys they can
destroy okay come we did so we've got
you know some some impartial observer
like I dunno
captain america something and he keeps a
careful tally and this is the ratio that
he observes okay for every five robots
that Thor gets Hulk gets six I don't
know where I do that by the way is on
this really important word which kind of
glides by with actually noticing him
respectively that's right now
prospectively you seen this way before
but just to remind you what it means is
that the order here matches or
corresponds to the order in here yes so
it means that uh Oh gets five and Hulk
gets six at least that's the ratio right
so I that's the comparison and that's
what respectively dudes so now we get a
bit of extra information about the
actual number not the ratio not the
proportion the actual number that Thor
got how many did popular or I could just
as easily have asked how many did they
do in total okay so I'm gonna show you
two methods for this which are both
messes you've seen before but maybe not
in this context okay so method number
one do you remember we said ratios are
just another kind of number you've
already met just address stuff
differently
fractions right there just fraction okay
because everything you can do with
fractions you can do it ratios so method
one is going to be called equivalent now
I could call this either equivalent
fractions or equipment right here's but
being ugh I've got ratio to you I'm
going to call it equivalent ratios the
although all the way
like tools and a dog persistent that I
need all the same as those from
equivalent fractions so he does method
one now what I'm gonna say is I'll stay
with what they say is this ratio here
five to six five to six
it should be equal to now I'm keeping it
respectively right four is the first
number four represents this first number
here okay so this ratio is equal to
another ratio 45 to something else but I
don't know okay and there's something
else I don't know is how many hot gun so
what I've got here is this ratio and
this ratio they're the same okay so how
do I go from five to forty five what
what transformation do I do okay yeah
good so I can I can do this in my
direction being that I've written arrow
this way if you go this way you'd divide
my night if you would be other way I'm
gonna multiply by knife now I actually
think probably in this case going that
way is more useful and the reason why is
because I know this stuff bacchus so to
get over that way
I just do the same thing so if I've got
to clear the fractions here equivalent
ratios together one to the other
I'll do the same operation which is
multiplication on my knife okay and I
think some jewelry worked out 6 times 9
is 54 so now there's my working but keep
in mind I come back to the question and
I wonder what was the actual thing they
wanted what what question about the
answer and that is how many even help
destroy the only number I'm really
interested is this one that I've done
here okay so I'm just gonna tie it up in
a nice neat bow and conclude down the
internet there for
Troy done okay
so you can see this just that some of
difference between the working idea to
get my own time and the actual answer
that I love okay you're happy with that
oh okay okay all right now that was that
was approach number one okay it's
another approach which again we've seen
before
you may remember when we would have a
look at GST it's cold the unitary method
I wonder if this on this title rings a
bell even if you don't remember how it
works as is implied by the name that you
needed to remit that is all about well
one of the units in this question and
what are the units so I'll guide you
through this thing you see how they say
this five to six five or six so that
means that 45 represents five units in
this question okay there are this many
units and 45 represents five units okay
so if I say five units equals 45 robots
okay five course mister 45 okay
therefore I can very easily work out
what one unit is right in the same way
that I did to multiply by 9 I'm gonna
divide by nine this is a suggestion
there okay so five units is that there
for one year equals divided by nine five
sorry night because you were dividing by
five now that I know what that is I can
work out any number of like if this was
five to seek surface five to sixty if
punkers having a good day or whatever it
is okay I just want to go to whatever
that second number is okay so from line
1 to line 2 I divided by five and now
what I want is hulkshare which was six
units I'll say six years okay so I'm
gonna take that in my book I mean this
is exactly what I did before right just
dressed up slightly differently and I
will multiply it by
okay so you can see from this line to
this line you divide it and then from
this line to this line if I multiply it
okay by the way this five in this six
you can see they correspond exactly to
this five and this is right so you can
see the same numbers appearing just in a
slightly different arrangement okay
again let's just conclude there for Hulk
destroy 54 okay now um two ways to go
two choices you can make or one twice
with two options depending on the
question you get either one would be
morphine but they were both as you can
see get you that same answer okay so in
the questions that I'm gonna give you
shortly
sometimes the method will be specified
for you please just this way please just
that way all the times it'll be like
well you can do it however you like at
least for one or two of those questions
I'd like you to try both and just see
well which one ended up being simpler
which one fit in my brain a little more
which one made more sense different
questions will lend you more in one way
versus the other okay